the white pieces in game two of course
duda will have the white pieces a total
of four games to decide the match and
here we go the finals has started we
have the end of the 2021 season it is
imminent now because the games have
started it's a queensborough opening for
magnus carlsen will we see the queen's
gambit will we see the nimzo indian
defense it's the queen's gambit
what a way to end the tour finals uh
yeah with the queen's gambit especially
after the year we've had yeah but okay
here we have an unusual move because
after porn takes born
while uh knight takes born was on the
board
not the most common move no but a trendy
one the semi-tarrash defense and now
magnus instead of pushing pawns in the
center instead of initiating really
direct play after a set of pawn traits
has just solidified his pawn center and
a couple more pawns have left the board
we have actually almost seen a
transposition to the karakon defense to
the c3 sicilian to other openings both
players definitely have prepared and wow
magnus carlsen has sacrificed a pawn
black with this last move just brought
his queen out attacking a white pawn
look at the sea lion right now black's
queen is eyeing up a pawn magnus just
said i don't care i'm not going to
defend it so huge huge tension already
at this early stage magnus with his rook
move tempting duda to take a pawn but
duda said no he wasn't brave enough he
didn't take that pawn because that would
have cost a lot of time with the black
yeah and i have to say suddenly we are
in the territory not of quite a novelty
but it's only ever been played once
before are you surprised by this last
movie ivanka white is still maintaining
this offer of a free pawn but now it's
even more tempting to grab this pawn for
black because if black's queen comes and
takes that white pawn just zooms down
this line suddenly it's check and white
can't block the check if black white
blocks with a piece then white actually
loses further material white would lose
another piece white i think has to move
the king you called it david at the
beginning
okay yeah it's on the board but i mean
here is like the case of the mind games
the reason i would just i would have
taken that pawn automatically is because
here black has so many different moves
that could retreat the queen black could
bring his bishop out to several squares
yes white have might have studied this
position yes it might still be promising
for white but magnus can't have analyzed
everything in depth and has a winning
advantage so magnus needs to attack now
and that attack involves pushing harry
the h-born up the board already yeah
pushing this h-born that means that
magnus actually wants to develop his
rook in the corner that white rook wants
to shift it up the board white's not
going to castle anymore so the rook is
not going to come towards the center of
the wood it's going to lift itself up
and
shift across and this is really creative
this is a unique position as ivanka
mentioned okay duda castles kingside
meanwhile magnus has chosen one of the
candidate moves that we were discussing
white has lifted up his rook so not the
traditional way we see a rook develop
itself but from here the rook could just
swing across one square maybe eye up the
black king also indirectly there are
threats against black's queen right now
bishop takes born check and invite the
king to take a step forward yeah so
right now black has moved his knight to
the side if he hadn't done this for
example if he just pushed a pawn then we
would have seen white play bishop takes
pawn check and after the king recaptures
the knight would jump out the way and
now we see why white's rook positioned
itself on the third rank it's eyeing up
the black queen this would have been a
deadly discovered attack black's knight
is a bit stuck and now white has taken
the opportunity to leap into the center
and again look at this an x-ray vision
attack against the black queen again a
huge threat now black has to move this
queen away because if he doesn't if dude
gets careless then suddenly bishop takes
pawn check would win the black queen so
dude right now has to avoid this trap he
has to retreat this queen away in this
direction or in this direction yeah he
wants to save the game and he retreats
to the edge of the board actually right
now there might be a direct way forward
a direct continuation first magnus
starts by bringing his rook across very
sensible that rook already is making the
black king feel very uncomfortable of
meeting white's threats because if you
touch your knight then suddenly the
queen will come forward so you don't
want to be doing that okay so he
sidesteps with his king into the corner
and magnus immediately developing his
bishop look at this white's knight in
the center of the board is beautiful
it's imperious it's dominating
everything that's what you defined as an
octonaut ivanka controlling eight great
squares now look at the two white
bishops the white light squared bishop
pointing towards the black king this
dark square bishop now about to remove
black's best defender the knight
white queen getting ready to jump into
the action white's rooks also both on
great lines if you look at black's rook
in the top left corner doing nothing
black's light squared bishop still
asleep black's queen offside nearly
every time he converts this nine times
out of ten pretty much he'll win a
position like this one on instagram says
that they will also be rooting for
wesley so he hoped to see him become
champion okay and uh the queen has moved
first ivanka white did sacrifice a piece
white gave up his bishops and then he
brought his queen out so magnus right
now is a whole piece down wow he's a
whole bishop down but look at the white
queen look at the white rook next to her
look at the white knight in the center
of the board they are shifting towards
that black king meanwhile what are black
pieces doing
i don't see that black queen ever
rejoining the action in time white's big
threat in the current position is
actually to just shift the white queen
up one square and then go for that weak
black pawn on the h line in front of the
black king that pawn is defenseless
i think it's almost game over and wow
that is reflected in the evaluation bar
plus seven right now virtually game over
only 18 moves in yeah masterpiece by
magnus so far
wow talk about a fast start
yeah and if i'm going to blame something
i think it would be capturing that pawn
that was offered i mean it was
just the continuation was perhaps a
little bit too
precise for duda to navigate yeah i
think he should have taken it i think
i'm glad he took it just from a
spectator's point of view it's really
instructive to show that okay you can
give up pawns and
the time that it takes your opponent to
steal these pawns gives you enough time
to attack but oh wow okay just as i say
that we do see a result i think young
christoph duda has resigned after only
18 moves magnus carlton wins the game
what a start to the tour finals for
world champion magnus crossing winning
the first game against young christophe
duda a tough start for the 23 year old
he will have the white pieces in the
next game